c'est le moment où jamais hein avec Muma
de dire ce que tu penses de moi abordez
jamais dit
vraiment allez là allez bonsoir Philippe
chevalier bonsoir PAL bonsoir Mireille
que des cartons hein que des succès avec
des répliques cultes c'est vous qui
voyez qui voyez on nous le dit souvent
on nous le dit dans la rue bien sûr ah
bah oui c'est vous qui voyez bien c'est
un peu comme le 22 à anère de Fernand
Renault une phrase qu'on avait pas
écrite he non c'est venu en
en improvisant après vous êtes dit ça
fait bouche ah oui ça marchait pas mal
et vous faites rire vous-même on se
connaî tellement bien qu'on sait ce qui
va le je sais ce qui va le faire rire il
sait ce qui va me faire rire il faut
dire 30 ans de compagnonnage c'est V vie
de couple professionnellement j'entends
non mais c'est c'est énorme dans C merci
de le signaler mais Régis alors vous pas
laassz quand même de jouet les imbéciles
vous diplômz des beauards oui ouais ou
fils d'une mère peintre et d'un père
photograp c'est vrai artiste j'ai passé
Mo où j'étais dans le milieu artiste et
donc je suis déjà j'ai commencé à aller
au beauzard et je suis resté 5 ans j'ai
eu le diplôme et ensuite j'ai eu envie
d'essayer le théâtre et là c'était
vraiment une évidence pareil pour vous
Philippe diplômé en droit c'est ça
licence de droit licence de droit
ancien président de la cour de nî c'est
du c'est du sérieux pourquoi vous avez
abandonné les la licence de droit vous
deviez devenir magistrat non non non non
en fait le droit m'a toujours cassé les
pieds je voulais faire des lettres et
puis on se disait vous savez quoi vous
avez votre Bag vous êtes j'étais nul en
math donc je dis bon ben je vais faire
du droit et puis le droit me casser les
pieds je voulais arrêter tout de suite
alors j'ai péniblement poursuivi après
avoir redoublé la trè année avoir échoué
en maîtrise alors j'ai quand Mme eu un
diplôme de criminologie bon mais le
droit me casser les pieds et je suis
allé au coursimon j'ai rencontré lapalè
enfin voilà on est là parce qu'on était
nul en math en fait comme beaucoup
d'arti on était nul en mat oui si on
était pas bon en math tout le monde
disait ben il fera rien lui de toute
façon il fera donc c'est le théâtre qui
vous a sauvé sinon vous étiez des
enfants perdus si j'ai bien compris sans
collier sans collier pauvre et votre
père premier président de la cour
d'appel de N il a dû être catastrophé
quand vous avez commencé parce m'ait
toujours dit non il voulait il voulait
quand même que je fasse des études donc
c'est ce que j'ai fait mais il était il
adorait les comiques et tout ça donc il
m'a toujours dit tu finiras sur les
planches bon bah j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai
suivi finalement les prescriptions
paternelles et il a été bon il est mort
maintenant il y a 25 ans mais on était
au théâtre de Bouvard à ce moment-là
déjà donc ça l'a un peu rassuré et vous
aussi a oui oui mais c'est la télé dès
qu'on pense à la télé tout le monde est
rassuré il y a que ceux qui passe à la
télé qui sont pas rassurési oh non mais
ça va là vous êtes mais tranquille ceux
qui vous c'est
vrai et et et dites-moi donc 30 ans
d'amitié et oui pardon oui oui d'amitié
oui oui vous vouliez dire quelque chose
non ben non je voulais non allez-y non
non non finissez finissez sur la pièce
par rapport à la lassitude de jouer mais
moi j'aime jouer ces personnages j'ai
toujours aimé ça c'est un grand plaisir
de jouer les les imbéciles comme ça ah
vous répondez à la question de tout à
l'heure j'ai compris c'est grand
class vous êtes en décalage permanent
oui c'est bien j'ai la réponse à la
question de tout à l'heure c'est bien il
est comme ça dans la vie vous discutez
avec
lui je peux te le dire tu es courant de
ce que je pense de toi he puis là bon
c'est le moment où
jamaisin avec de dire ce que tu penses
de
moi jamais dit
vraimentz làz vous abordez un sujet a il
vous écoute bon vous passez à un sujet
bcout écoute très bien vous vous abordez
un troisème sujet il vous écoute
toujours il a dit quelques mots peser et
puis tout d'un coup alors qu'on est en
pleine conversation sur le sujet C il
répond à une question posée au sujet a
oui parce que là je me suis dit tiens en
fait tout à
l'heureali a tout à l'heure j'ai pas
répondu à du mal et là ça met'est voilà
oui ça était venu après voilà mais c'est
joli d'avoir une vraie démonstration
comme celle-ci justement mon en fait que
je suis bête en fait non que tu a
réfléchi et que je suis très doué pour
en fait que je ne fais aucun effort pour
jouer
pignon alors donc ma question non mais
je pense que oui alors la question
j'étais en train de poser quand vous
êtes revenu à celle d'avant hein vous me
suivez bien très bien moi je suis là
donc 30 ans d'amitié parce que vous êtes
amis dans la vie j'imagine c'est avant
tout une histoire d'amitié sin c'est
d'abord une histoire d'amitié bah oui
sinon on pourrait pas être toujours là
public le le ressentirait je pense même
si ça marchait on pourit pas tricher
jamais de dispute et jamais de tension
jamais de DISP bien sûr quel ça jamais
été très loin mais si des petits des
petits mais très très très très rares et
et rarement orageux c'est sur le boulot
mais plus que personnellement ou sur le
travail mais pas artistique sur la
promotion par exemple est-ce qu'en fait
elle oit l'émission de télé vous êtes
beaucoup disputé pour celle-ci est-ce
que c'est opportun d'aller alors là on a
dit oui tout de suite parce que c'est
une exception c'est exception
normalement
oui non c'est parfait on se dispute on
est moi je suis celui qui dit toujours
oui et régie c'est c'est son tempérament
aussi son caractère un peu dans la vie
et est un homme extrêmement prudent et
il il dit pas forcément non mais il est
il met en délibéré alors comme comme
comme aurait fait mon père qui était
magistrat lui il mettait en délibéré
régist il tient de mon père pour ça il
il met toujours b voilà mais moi je dis
toujours oui mais à la fin on est
d'accord il me retient un peu par le
colback et puis voilà mais bon et à quel
moment vous avez su que vous étiez drôle
au cours de théâtre parce que justement
là il y a une fois au bout de 3 mois
j'ai joué une grande scène et tout le
monde était mort de rire et on m'a
laissé continuer pendant 10 minutes mais
là une scène dramatique c'était pas
vraiment du comicque c'était du
Jean-Claude Grimbert mais
euh tout le monde était mort de rire et
là là j'ai eu un j'étais très
déstabilisé parce que je comprenais pas
pourquoi il riait et le lendemain on m'a
convoqué on m'a dit vous êtes un comique
lapis alors là cette foislà je
comprenais enfin ouais c a fallu le
dépasser quoi voilà à partir de ce
momentl je j'ai après j'ai su pourquoi
et ça m'a plu vous vous souvenez de
Rosine Marga bien sûr bien sûr qui était
la directrice du Simon du cour Simon qui
nous a quitté cet été elle vous secouait
elle hésitait pas à vous
vérit alors on l'avait revu quand même
on l'avait revu deux fois et notamment
au 80 ans du cour simonou Francis
suuster et vous pensez vraiment Philipe
oui comme comme elle le dit Rosine Marga
vous auriez fait peut-être une autre
carrière si vous n'aviez pas rencontré
vous Régis je suis désolé hein tu te
rends compte où tu pourrais être
maintenant je su c'estd j'amanderai un
petit peu son propos parce que j'adore
comme il parle j'amanderai un petit peu
oui oui bah comme comme les politiques
hein mais j'ai mais c'est pas moi qui
est de cravate j'allais dire que c'est
l'étudiant droit qui oui peut-être oui
ah ça c'est vrai oui oui en revanche ce
qui se passe c'est que je pense qu'avec
le
temps ma confrontation le fait de me
frotter à laaspalais fait que lui c'est
une telle force comique c'est un tel
monollythe comique c'est une telle vice
comica que vous vous vous paraissez
moins vous paraissez forcément moins
comique ou comique d'une autre nature à
côté de lui et je crois que c'est ça
parce que moi j'étais parti plutôt
même à 20 ans pourra être aussi un peu
un Auguste et un bet vous l'appelez l'pè
non je l'appelle l'espinace et je
l'appelle
Robert c'est cette histoire dans les
interviews je l'appelle Robert
lesespinaceerin c'est infectueux ça et
vous vous l'appelez comment Philippe il
m'appelle pas non je t' pas de nom ENF
téléphone pas mais vous dites chevalier
vous dites Philippe non mon gars il dit
mon gars oui mon gars mon gar mon petit
gars très prot mais il est très
protecteur faut dire qu'il est beaucoup
plus vieux que moi hein il a 15 ans de
plus que moi oui c'est ça vous avez quel
âge d'ailleurs l'un et l'autre ah bah
c'est lui qui est tout de suite
évidemment moi j'ai j'ai 54 ans ah bon
oui oh là là je moi je dirais jamais mon
âge comme ça il est coquette c'est
incroyable oh là
attends personne dit ça là attend Luini
l'autre jour il a dit qu'il avait 2
c'est pas forcément vrai on a 13 mois
d'écart alors je voudrais maintenant que
l'on regarde vous allez voir alors on
replonge dans les années 80 83
exactement avec le petit théâtre de
Bouvard qui vous a quand même lancé
propulsé
exactement le vôtre est plus gros que le
mien au débutand je l'ai eu il était
tout
petit il a grossi peu à peu quand j'ai
vu pour la première fois chevalier et
lapalaise j'ai eu l'impression que
c'était une entrée de clown j'ai tout de
suite vu que c'était des gens
exceptionnels ils s'étaient déjà choisis
ils étaient déjà paxés si je puis dire
ensemble moi j'ai profité de leur
mariage moi voyez je le sors surtout le
matin pendant que ma femme est encore au
lit
non moi ça dépend un coup le soir un
coup le
matin il y a pas de
règles il tire beaucoup le
vôtre je les considère comme mes enfants
je leur trouve de plus en plus de talent
et j'ai envie de leur dire que leur
combat n'était pas gagné au départ
on les avait un peu ringardisé bon allez
c'est pas tout mais il faut que je le
rentre le mien maintenant là le mien
aussi il commence à faire
froid allez tu viens popole ah le votre
aussi il s'appelle
popo et que je vois qu'ils sont devenus
les comiques préférés des intellectuel
et ben j'avoue que je suis très fier
d'eux vous saviez que vous étiez les
comiques préférés des intellectuels d'AB
on est très touché à chaque fois de voir
Philippe à qui nous sommes très très
fidèles parce qu'on a pour lui autant
d'admiration et de respect que
d'affection et je crois qu'il nous rend
cette affection et alors ce qui est
amusant dans ce que dit Philippe c'est
alors c'est sa dernière trouvaille là ça
je ne savais pas c'est que nous sommes
les comiques préférés des intellectuels
alors voilà mais vous n'avez pas
souffert comme il le dit d'avoir été
ringardisé à un certain moment ou si
oui des critiques des critiques pe-être
si il dit ça avec une si parce que come
on jouit des ringars personnages ringar
on était un peu pauvre de de
franchouillard et cetera c'est c'est
parfois malvenu dans certains dans
certains cénacles le sketch des femmes
par exemple qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
alors on étit traité de misogyne des
fois par des critiques et ça ça alors
que c'est un sketch sur la misogynie où
on montre deux deux cons qui qui sont
misogy ça veut dire qu'on incarne la
connerie et la bouffitude avec avec un
naturel ça il faut pas le rejeter je
crois qu'il faut maintenant c'est rentré
dans
l'ordre ça y est maintenant tout le
monde a compris mais bon ils ont mis du
temps des fois car Régis c'est un dandit
non pas qu'on ignore et qui s'ignore non
plus mais c'est vrai que il est toujours
habillé tiré à cping habillé chez les
chaussé chez les meilleurs chausseurs
chemisé chez les meilleurs
chemisiers il est extrêmement coquet
alors l'un et l'autre pas d'enfant pas
d'enfant non ah bah là ça y est on est
ve publique vie pr oui bah oui quand
même quand même pas d'enfant on est
dedans on est dedans avant de recevoir
Francis Weber ah ouis oui B non mais bon
oui on a pris un peu de retard un petit
peu un petit peu de retard mais ça que
vous allez combler trop de
retard je pense ouii je je me Perm parce
que quand même vous avez dit un petit
peu vous aviez l'air ne me permettrait
pas pessimiste enfin bon moi pour ne
rien vous cacher je vis avec quelqu'un
en ce moment une charmante jeune fille
adorable que j'embrasse au passage
est-ce que je vais avoir des enfants
avec elle je ne sais pas je verrai mais
c'est c'est à l'ordre du jour mais pas
immédiat voilà il faut voir voilà très
bonne réponse ou il faut voir tout ça
vous savez c'est que on est très pudique
hein vous avez vu c'est que le début on
est très très pudique on a quand même
non mais on peut le dire sérieusement on
a beaucoup non pas sacrifié mais on a
passé énormément de temps à à faire
notre métier et et à s'occuper de notre
métier parce qu'on écrivait parce qu'on
jouait on était sur scè direou vra
beaucoup de temps sur scène en tourné
mais on est pas marié et on n pas
d'enfants voilà alors je vous propose
maintenant d'accueillir celui qui a
écrit entre autres le fameux dîner de
con dans lequel vous triomphez
actuellement au Théâtre des Variétés
succès ininterrompu de cette pièce
depuis
1993 c'est cela que vous avez aussi
adapté au cinéma d'ailleurs au cinéma et
c'est étonnant de voir la différence
d'interprétation c'est très rigolo de
voir çaoua ou et et d'accord vous avec
le metteur en scène Jean-Luc morreau
c'est c'est l'un des duos qui
fonctionne en fait si vous voulez il y a
un bémol à mettre qui est que on peut
c'est très difficile pour un auteur de
juger ce qui fonctionne le mieux ou pas
le mieux ils sont tous satisfaisants
mais il y a une chose qu'ils ont par
rapport aux autres et qu'avit Poiré co
c'est l'habitude l'un de l'autre parce
que bon lui on peut pas parler de son
comic il est tellement évident si vous
voulez que ça serait idiot c'est pres
qu'un pléonas de dire qu'il est drôle
mais il est très très plus qu'à partir
on parle
pas et puis en plus il a une chance
régisse c'est d'avoir un contre-chant de
comédie qui a de l'énergie et c'est très
difficile Philippe est celui qui
démultiplie les effets du comic donc il
faut qu'il ait à la fois de la
générosité et de la force vous dites
toujours ce que vous pensez vous parlez
vrai et vous venez de le prouver encore
dans votre livre de mémoire que vous
avez peut-être lu hein que vous publiez
chez Robert Laffond que ça reste entre
nous et et d'ailleurs vous parlez du
succès aussi du dîner de con avec Arthur
et Dan boun vous expliquez comment
bienvenue chez les Chtis à un peu
perturbé les représentations du
spectacle torpillé pas perturbé du tout
c'est-à-dire que tout à coup des
carentiers de chtis sont arrivés au
théâtre c'était plus le théâtre de la
Porte Saint-Martin c'était les du Nord
ils arrivaient dans la salle et il
criaiit bilout et et l'autre a repris
l'accent chti en jouant ce qui fait que
je sais plus quelle était la pièce
exactement c'était très curieux et il a
été obligé d'arrêter parce qu'il a une
telle promotion un tel succès avec sa sa
piè avec son film que la pièce en apâti
ce qui c'est pas très grave d'ailleurs
parce que ensuite la tournée est partie
avec vous et j'ai pas regretté alors
vous avez parlé ensemble avant
d'interpréter sa pièce ou avec franc ah
mais vous connaissez quand
même on s déjà rencontré Francis était
déjà venu nous voirè dans dans Monsieur
chasse la pièce de F et on s'était vu un
quart d'heure en fait c'est pas comme ça
que ça s'est passé du tout j'ai j'ai
j'ai j'ai eu une courte liaison avec
réis ah ben on le dit dans ce métier il
faut coucher pour
réussir et c'est régist qui s'est dévoué
il s'est dévoué voilà non c'est comme ça
que s passé mais enf Savit pour les
avoir vu en tourné qui tenait bien la
pièce en main en fait et comment vous
est venu cette idée justement de faire
ça de voilà de la pièce pa detc bah vous
savez j'avais entendu parler que ça se
jouait à Paris à une époque c'estàdire
qu'il y avait des méchants en général
c'estàdire c'était un jeu qui était
pratiqué il y avait des méchant voilà
c'était la bande de chez Castel je me
rappelle des jeunes gens riches qui se
choisissait le con le plus performant et
se moquit de lui pendant tout un rep
jeu cruel ouais c'est un jeu cruel et on
m'a raconté une histoire c'est Jacques
Martin qui me l'a raconté Jacques Martin
était donc invité à un de ses dîner en
tant qu'inviteur et il avait un con à
amener il avait trouvé quelqu'un de très
bien mais son con est tombé malade alors
il a appelé Castel à foler en disant
est-ce que tu aurais pas un compte de
secours et Castelle lui a dit si il lui
a donné le nom d'un réalisateur de télé
qui paraî-il était vraiment pas le plus
doué du bataillon je dirais pas son nom
alors Martin a appelé le type en disant
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler de vous il
paraît vous êtes remarquable comme homme
j'aimerais vous connaître mieux est-ce
qu'on pourrait aller dîner à tel endroit
chez Castel dit ben je peux pas je suis
déjà invité il avait déjà été pris par
quelqu'un
d'autre et en même temps mais c'est
épouvantable c'est vrai que c'est un jeu
épouvantable ah c'est terrifiant
terrifiant pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Ina Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche